there are two more features i wanted to
mention on inputs the required attribute
and the placeholder attribute required
just lets me say this field is required
before you can submit the form so for
example if i want to make sure that my
lemur aficionados enter a telephone
number i can do that right on the input
now if i try to go into this field and
let's say i don't want to give a
telephone number so i just skip it and i
try to submit the form it tells me that
I have to fill that filled out the other
feature is the placeholder text you may
want to give hints to your users in some
fields that go away when they start
typing you can do that pretty easily by
just setting a placeholder attribute and
now you can tell i get placeholder text
in that field but once i start typing
something it goes away none of this
removes the need for server side
validation of course but it does make it
easier for your users not to
accidentally submit something that's not
valid and it doesn't require any
JavaScript on your page to do that or to
provide placeholder text that gets out
of the users way